yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing a hollow one the hollow one
maybe okay I'm trying
the London system for a change
I usually don't fare all that well with
those systems but okay I think I'm happy
to play c4 after all getting a little
bit something that I know a little bit
more the structure
I wonder isn't in that little bit better
for me my development isn't good yeah
I'm perfectly aware right before I
thought I'd just take actually may have
to I could I have to take otherwise this
doesn't make any sense I was expecting
to be eight
you
I think I'll do that it looks extremely
slow but if I get denied to a five this
position will be fantastic without any
any sort of counter plane and be before
next
yeah it's difficult for him to make
anything happen here I just play rook HD
191 f3 e4 slowly push things forward
there's nothing to attack really
[Music]
three for that blunts the bishop and
then I can actually improve my night
finally yeah we need five yeah so I
should not allow any trickery but I
don't see much happening I mean I'd be
too probably wasn't really dangerous but
I can keep things controlled and if you
can it's a good idea to do so just
prevent anything eight maybe just Knight
to f4 Knight c5 it probably will go back
to C eight or so okay ninety-five
doesn't do all that much
nope not 95 he takes and blocks it
there's no need to do it now actually
night a six is hard to prevent with the
bishop on f7
yeah no just one spycheck
yeah enunciate Queen is really
threatened
so how am i how am i promoting now
b7 I can actually play this huh if it
takes with the piece that's b7 maid and
King takes I can play Bishop 86 yeah
that's what happens if you play those
show-off moves yeah you know
it was stupid okay and I hope this sexy
could've played okay I did you know the
position it was it could stand some
mistakes yeah I think in the opening he
played one or two decisions that were a
bit too quick and then it was
problematic for him all of a sudden I'm
I'm not quite sure here okay the engine
likes my decision so here I was not
totally sure because um I was thinking a
quicker would be eight might be okay
played here not 93 and now a night
before I was thinking of this move I can
actually cancel Oh hmm yeah I was
thinking b3 you and but this debt wasn't
clear to me I because here and then 85
and I wasn't completely sure here yeah
and the computer agrees this is a
compensation for black so maybe
something else that's interesting
I never would have played it I mean
absolutely no chance this may be M 496
castles b3 yeah yeah maybe I am slightly
better but I wasn't sure but I'm very
sure that I'm much better now because
here I'm keeping my porn for for a huge
advantage once this was established it
was just winning yeah okay took I played
this pretty stupid move down that show
of move that was completely out of place
just look very funny there is this I
computer sorry seeing a checkmate yeah a
seven of course I was just some of hey I
like the I can take a six it's just
stupid I mean the position thankfully is
so good that it could against 10th as
this stupid move ok guys thanks for
watching